he's named but I haven't announced it
you haven't announced it yet I haven't
announced it yet well fast forward a few
weeks and Khloe Kardashian and Tristan
Thompson's son's name has finally been
revealed it's such a beautiful thing
drum roll please his name is Tatum so
Tatum and true yep Tatum I love it Coco
confirmed her baby's name during the
season three premiere of who lose the
Kardashians naming a human is really
hard I feel like I've gone through a lot
recently what's one more thing on my
plate of course Chloe and Tristan share
a five-year-old daughter true and
welcome their second child together back
in July via surrogate I've been on the
fence about having Tristan come to the
hospital or not but this Tristan wants
to be here so I just figured why not let
him come I'll never get this moment back
cameras were rolling in the hospital
immediately after his birth but Chloe
and Tristan decided not to share his
name a choice Chloe explained last month
during a stop by the Jennifer Hudson
show at first I really did not know what
I was going to name him I wanted to meet
him and feel him out a little bit and so
at first he didn't have a name Chloe
teased that her baby's name starts with
a T just like his big sister true and
Dad Tristan he is a quiet baby he's a
happy baby which is amazing and she was
planning on sharing his moniker soon
he's been named but I've been waiting
for the premiere of our show and I
didn't know it was going to be this far
out so now I'm just like if my daughter
outs me I'm screwed last season Chloe
revealed that she did an embryo transfer
to have a baby via surrogate just days
before news broke that the NBA star had
bothered a child with another woman
claiming Tristan knew he was having a
baby with someone else but still pushed
Coco to move forward with the surrogacy
process it's just so close I wouldn't
want anyone to think I did this after
the fact
why would I want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else I was definitely very
angry and I think
feeling
Bamboozled I think that you have a real
insight into what the girls are doing
not only you know what you see in the
press or whatever but what's really
happening behind the scenes and we're
seeing more in front of cameras too on
social media the glimpses are rare but
we're loving seeing little moments with
true and Tatum on Coco's Instagram